i'm so excited to meet you in person i
am so excited honestly and drew your
kitchen is gorgeous the moody foodie
likes it i'm so happy
i love it i love it you understand what
a stamp of approval that is um the moody
foodie is so perfect um when and where
did you come up with that name i thought
i feel like when it comes to food
everyone always asks what are you in the
mood for and it's like everyone's always
asking like do you want thai chinese
mexican food what are you in the mood
for and i thought moody foodie i think
it's perfect oh like it's a mood as well
because it's true what are you in the
mood for
oh
and i feel like with food it's like not
only is the food delicious but you
accept the mood put the right song on
light some candles and you have like
this delicious dish it's all about the
mood well i'm so excited because the
dish that you wanted to bring
you picked literally one of my favorite
all-time dishes of my life that i have
been eating since i was a child one of
my number one favorite foods in the
world chili kelas
so
if there's anyone i want to learn this
from it's you will you please teach all
of us i would love to teach you all how
to make chile i mean first of all it's a
very instagramable dish it's like a
beautiful looking dish and it tastes
amazing so
let's start off i think the first step
especially if you're like us starting to
cook which i know that you cook a lot
but for anyone starting to i always feel
like i'm starting yeah it doesn't matter
so do i i'm not culinarily trained like
at all oh god i mean you you're a home
car really i'm shocked because you just
and also you know what you have is like
patience and grace two things i
completely lack
um so okay how do we start we're going
with the onion well first of all i like
to start off with i'd like to throw a
towel around my shoulder so it looks
like i know what i'm doing i feel like
everyone that does this you just lean
over the counter you have a towel and
everyone's like that's a cook um okay so
we roast onions and tomatoes on a sheet
pan is that how you yeah you can do it
on a sheet pan a cast iron kind of
whatever you have
you just char up the tomatoes and the
onions and the garlic which in mexican
cooking it's very common to see this
adds so much flavor to it and then we
have right here some
guajillo and chile de arbol which is
very common again in mexican cooking
some mexican oregano salt and pepper and
we just toss that all in and we've uh
boiled these peppers down a little bit
so they're nice and soft and the good
thing about these is it's what's your
spice tolerance true
i love spices perfect because we have
plenty of the little ones the little
ones are very spicy but the good thing
is in mexican cooking we use a lot of
chilies but they're not all super spicy
they just add a lot of flavor and the
seeds will also determine how much
seedage absolutely yeah so you can if
you don't really want to be super spicy
but you like the flavor stick out the
seeds and you're good to go perfect so
we pop this in and then we just pull
someone low
there we go now right here we're just
gonna add some broth
and just like eyeball it
and if it looks like saucy
i think it looks there's three spouts
and i didn't get one right i think a
little bit went into the blender it
looks it looks a little bit wet into the
blender and all of it went everywhere
else so uh yeah so then basically just
going to want to add the sauce onto the
pan and like cook it down just a little
bit
um and then this is called epasote and
this herb is amazing if you can find it
at mexican grocery store it's like
citrusy it's it's very pungent oh wow
peppery and like a little minty
wow it's a phenomenal so if you can find
it
it's fantastic and with this it's pretty
simple it's pretty pungent so i just
like to add a few like leaves right here
keep it on the stem and then you just
kind of like slap it in the pan
and then at the end we're just gonna
remove it and then once the sauce is
down then what do we do all right so
we're just gonna take this out i'm just
gonna use this little fork right here to
like take this out
and uh
then you kind of like discard that i
want to just toss it i'm going to put
that in my favorite
then you grab these beautiful things and
these are called tottopos they're
they're just torchy chips uh but i'm
actually called
when you see them like this you're like
oh so much love oh absolutely so
homemade oh i like to toss them into the
sauce but i mean you do your thing oh no
wait you're teaching me tell me what to
do i see i'm not gonna do it right
you're good they're gonna teach me so
then you just cover these up and like i
said earlier like it's a very
instagramable
dish now that i've coated it all do i
plate yes and so i just like like to
like
spoon this in
like kind of let it like look organic
but also with a lot of intention and
then we're gonna have this fun like
chipotle assembly line situation so we
wipe this down and then
crema yeah crumb and this is also like
you can make this like super vegan if uh
if
you are vegan this dish can be
completely veganized and i like to add
the crema just because that's satisfying
oh we went very different methods
i i i like it very like jackson pollock
i went in a hypnotic circle you went
ziggity zaggety okay you're an artist
which layer next um i like to add the
i like to add the onion okay good i'm
asking you because i i really do want to
follow you even if i do it a little
differently like i know your steps are
going to be better than my methodologies
okay next i like to add the um the egg
on top
and
just plop that on like right there i
mean how beautiful are these eggs by the
way they're so gorgeous they're so
pretty
um okay next uh then i like to add the
cheese and then just like crumble it on
here and what i like about the crema and
the cheese is it if you like it spicy
it's just like that nice little cooling
effect that you get and then after that
i like to top it off with just a little
bit of cilantro and i don't like to chop
it i just like to throw it on there yep
and then you just toss up a lime i'm a
huge fan of lime on like every food
that was beautiful what do you think
it has been a dream of mine to work with
you please please please can we do this
again yes i would love that i would love
that so much
also known as the moody foodie check out
his videos if you're not one of the 70
million people already watching for this
recipe go to the drewberrymartian.com my
very first chiliquilas with you you look
so good side by side thank you so much
we'll be right back
[Music]